à 10 ans sont luc ferrandez bonsoir
je ne peux pas être contre ça mais
d'abord je vous montre les candidats à
laval parce qu'on ne voit pas que parler
de montréal lors du jeu panel stéphane
boyer on vient de le voir avec sa
promesse d' espaces verts michel
trottier du parti laval il se fit
trottier d'action laval j'imagine qu'ils
sont pas parents les deux je reviens la
promesse de monsieur boyer luc ferrandez
ce genre de promesses que vous devez
aimer ça absolument c'est excellent
c'est fantastique il faut le faire il a
tellement raison c'est un projet
enthousiasmant
linverse serait inadmissible
mais quand même un petit bémol pas de
bémol mais regardons les chiffres laval
en ce moment à trois parcs nature avec
qui totalise 60 hectares
l'administration demers en a acheté 40
et donc au coût de 35 millions de
dollars les deux ensemble ça sente
hector le propose en ajouter 500 c'est
extraordinaire c'est fantastique ça
multiplie par 5 n'est pas les espaces
naturels genre de projet que j'ai rien
mais faire oui d'ailleurs ça va se faire
aussi sur le côté de montréal avec
variés munich est acheté l'île il est le
saint joseph mais mais même en faisant
cela 5 500 hectares plus les sept
hectares il arrive à 600 hectares à
montréal l'autre côté une île un peu
plus gros son centre trois mille
hectares sont préservés 3000 donc laval
avait un énorme déficit des espaces
nature et avec ça et prennent une très
grosse bouche espérons qu'ils vont y
arriver mais ça ne suffira pas il faut
protéger 18 il reste 18 boisé sur l'île
faut protéger des boisés qu'il faut
protéger des golfs les golfs qu'il faut
pas faire de changement de zonage sur
les golfs faut les laisser espaces verts
quand la durée de vie du golfe sera
terminé il faut protéger les berges
comme ils vont le faire il faut protéger
des milieux humides
moi évidemment je suis je suis convaincu
que ça va être un super projet vient de
là bas si c'était ma course sur la barre
à sainte rose donc je connais très bien
l'endroit et c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour les lavallois
effectivement 550 hectares
et c'est pas mal plus grand que le
central père c'est beaucoup plus grand
que le mont royal à l'avant il faut se
rappeler qu'un tiers de leur territoire
c'était des tard avant le 7 des terres
agricoles il ya eu le passage d'un maire
que je nommerai pas qui a développé
beaucoup laval en dézonant des ondes
vertes et c'est pour ça que moi je vois
enfin cette lumière avec ce jeune
candidat à la mairie qui représente une
nouvelle génération donc c'est le sel
qui vient après l'annonce un vieux que
moi et celle là je veux près et vous
aussi ben oui s'cusez moi patrice ne
nommer
que ceux-là veulent protéger et ils y
ont une vue pour l'avenir et ce projet
là pour moi est un projet extrêmement
important bon je veux qu'on revoie les
trois photos l'indiana où plus des
candidats quel genre de lutte vous
entrevoyez à laval justement ce que
voyez comme il ya l'appui du maire
sortant il part avec une grande avance
annie rapidement mais rapidement la
voyez partout notamment avec le maire
demers le maire demers aussi quand même
un bilan des deux dernières années donc
il ya aussi acquérir deux ancres de deux
hectares pour le chemin de l'écart et
tout ça donc qui ont déjà un bilan
intéressant et positif faut se rappeler
pourquoi marc demers est arrivé ex
policier il est arrivé pour faire du
ménage dans la ville et se départir de
vie passé de l'ancien maire ce que fait
maintenant et repart puis laisse le jeu
n'est cependant le plafond lui que moi
jalili a une longueur d'avancé boyer oui
mais j'ai beaucoup aimé la presse que
monsieur michel trottier a dit il faut
mettre une partie des surplus de la
ville de laval pour continuer ce projet
là et pas juste 10% parce que là pour
l'instant ça va dépendre de la cmm donc
du projet
la ville verte et de l'ul le corridor
vert et bleu et c'est des sommes qui
arrivent au compte gouttes est ce que le
projet qui va se faire c'est sur 25 ans
30 ans 50 ans ou est-ce que laval peut
contribuer plus d'une fois plus
rapidement moi je m'attendais des
engagements concrets du côté de monsieur
boyer ce qui est formidable aussi c'est
la mise à niveau du plan d'urbanisme de
la ville de laval avec la création des
coeurs villageois avec la réflexion sur
les rues commerciales c'est aussi une
grande avancée qui n'avait jamais été
fait à laval à cause de la présence du
maire vaillancourt avant lui et donc et
beaucoup de beaux projets il faut que
les oppositions s'exprime comme ils
l'ont fait et
que l'aco les meilleurs gadgets
dithyrambique ce soit monsieur coderre
on en avait parlé ensemble on avait un
reportage là dessus sur cette question
de la hauteur des gratte-ciel à montréal
monsieur coderre qui jonglait avec
l'idée de permettre aux promoteurs de
dépasser le sacro saint mont royal et je
fais où je vous fait écouter monsieur
cola qui dit finalement pas une très
bonne idée mais quoi quand j'ai parlé du
mont royal je voulais évidemment
provoquer le débat donc il ya des gens
qui ont dit ça dépend de la perspective
qu on est d'où est ce qu'on se place
qu'est ce que ça me dit la hauteur du
mont royal fait qu'il faut prendre en
considération
bon j'imagine que c'est encore plus
clair l'extrait il referme la porte vous
riez luc ferrandez bah oui parce que
bravo à monsieur coderre de reculer sur
cet engagement qui n'était pas bon
félicitations les villes élégante du
monde n'ont pas besoin d'aidés ville
d'un mur de béton hauteur il s'en prend
de la hauteur mais on ne faut pas avoir
des corridors de d'immeubles avec 100
percées de soleil d'ailleurs bien
candide immeubles prévus sur la rue peel
dans le plan d'urbanisme moi qui me
ferait pas parce qu'il fait de l'ombre
âge au square dominion mais monsieur
coderre up entendu raison bravo bravo
bravo sa façon de reculer va est
amusante administration
vous connaissez bien monsieur coderre
donc un peu s'il
fait lille mais les touches finales à
son programme il veut enlever des sujets
qui pourraient être controversé ouais
mais je vous rappelle que moi aussi j'ai
sont les vg [ __ ] tantôt de relire ce
passage où on parlait de la hauteur et
j'ai relu le communiqué qui a émis
aujourd'hui j'ai des doutes il va
falloir que les mots réaliste soit très
vigilant parce que quand on dit qu'on
veut augmenter et on veut faire de
l'urbanisme et augmenter la densité
d'une façon douce et intelligente qu'est
ce que ça veut dire douce et
intelligente et on dit on n'est pas
d'accord avec le 20 20 20 parce que
c'est un programme qui est trop rigide
et on doit densifier le centre-ville
donc moi le doubs ça a été les jantes
densification du centre ville il faut
construire je me pose des questions est
ce que c'est juste parce que c'est la
campagne électorale et le lendemain
d'élections ben on va recommencer à
faire ça moi je vous dirais chers
électeurs soyez soyez présents soyez
l'un dans les consultations qui soyez
assurés que ça se passe bien parce que
douce et intelligente j'ai un peu de
difficulté dans un croyant électeurs à
venir si je peux me permettre de
compléter ce que tu dis tout à fait
c'est quoi la vision urbanistique
complète ou au delà de oui les auteurs
avaient diminué pour me dépasser leurs
mots royal c'est quoi cette vision de
centre-ville c'est quoi sa vision des
quartiers qui l'entourent ou effet de
tendre et cetera le vieux montréal
comment il va densifier de façon
intelligente puis de façon humaine de
façon urbanistiquement intégrer on
attend la réponse animation luc
ferrandez merci beaucoup c'est tout ça
qu'on a on va se revoir comme ça deux
fois par semaine jusqu'à l'élection du 7
novembre merci à très bientôt